[Music]
virtual panel my name is diagonal sir
I'm a second year MBA student at the GSB
and I'm joined by Hannah angle also a
second year MBA student here at the GSB
we'll be talking about our journey to
the GSB the student experience here on
campus and answer many of your questions
as many as we can in the 30 minutes that
we have we will choose questions that
most people are interested in based on
the poll results we won't be talking
about the admission process the
application or financial aid but you can
contact ya in da admissions office
directly in case you have questions of
any of these just made a question to us
please feel free to just click on the
Q&A button Q&A button at the bottom of
your screen so let's begin with
introductions enough neatly start by
telling us a little bit about yourself
where are you from what were you doing
before coming to the GSB and what are
your goals after graduation of course
links Diana I'm Hannah I'm originally
from South Florida I went to the
University of Miami for undergrad and
after Miami I decided to join the Navy
and I did that for six years as a supply
and logistics officer mostly focused in
Southeast Asia finished up in San Diego
and they decided to come to Stanford GSB
oh cool thanks as for myself I'm from
Jordan I was a product manager at Amazon
before joining the GSB and after
graduation I would like to still do
product management but probably in the
tech media space awesome so now this get
started with some of the questions
submitted by the audience so the first
question we have is why an mba what made
you decide this was the right time for
Business School you wanna take this one
of course so as I was deciding to get
out of the Navy I looked at the jobs
that were available to me and they're
mostly operations focused kind of
leading teams of 10 to 20 people pretty
similar to what I was doing in the
service I felt like Business School just
opens up the entirely different set of
doors you can pursue finance tech
consulting startups etc and I really
want to kind of open up my options and I
can tell you that after a year at
Stanford that really is the case
I don't feel like I'm pigeon holed into
operations and that there's a lot of
different industries I can pursue oh
yeah and this is actually very similar
to what I also wanted to do I I felt
that I just wanted to explore what's up
there in the universe and like what
other opportunities are available for me
and this wasn't the main reason why I
came for an MBA so yeah it's either if
you want to sort of change your industry
or change the function or something like
that I think that personally would drove
me to do my MBA cool so how would you
describe a typical class as temper GSB
in terms of diversity and background and
think I'll be interesting given your
background in the Navy so yeah can you
tell us a little a little bit about the
typical class at the GSB sure in terms
of classes in terms of a diversity
perspective the GSB is really good at
kind of curating this you know 40%
international 40-something percent women
X percent minorities LGBT and so you get
this really just diverse kind of
demographic background and that really
creates a much more fruitful discussion
and there's also ideological back
different backgrounds as well you see
people from all different ends of the
political spectrum all different levels
of a socio-economic background and I
think I just enables me to really learn
about my classmates and what they're
passionate about and just have a much
kind of better understanding of people
and what's out there yeah and I think
all sits at that point I feel that in
our classes we have a lot of different
at diverse cases that we study from like
as an international student I sometimes
see cases that are not only from the
United States but from businesses around
the world and I find this super
fascinating and you will point around
diversity and inclusion I really love
that I recently started publishing our
records of the rest and inclusion I
think that's a really good sign for this
school to also stress the importance of
you know the numbers that we publish
around diversity and inclusion so yeah
amazing how do you usually spend your
time after class definitely so
you honestly I feel like especially
first year you're deciding what not to
do because there are so many options you
can do something social and a small
group social it a large group something
professional something or you can spend
more time reading cases and working on
homework so it really is balancing that
academic professional and social kind of
areas and now second year it calms down
a little bit which is great so I mostly
figured out what I'm doing
professionally I'm gonna go into
consulting after business school so now
I spend most of my time on the social on
classes that I'm really passionate about
and want to kind of learn deeper and
then attending a lot of the really great
speakers that we have here at the GSB
yeah totally and I totally think the
same way especially for first year you
are super intentional about community
creation especially that we live there's
SS here at the GSB it just feels like
there is so much going on after class to
you know around community building going
to talk which is one of the most famous
traditions that we have in which
students share their their own personal
stories with the class I've just like
enjoyed getting to know my classmates
especially in the first year now I feel
like I have more control just to because
if I like cool I can take this one first
and I'll give you some time think about
it what have been some of your favorite
classes and why I'm taking this one cuz
I know I have oh my god like my favorite
she has been freedom democracy and
capitalism I keep Tennessee like as an
international student I was trying to
learn about the US and you know these
three pillars that define what the u.s.
is and I found this class fascinating
and it's always really amazing to me how
the GSB offers classes that not only
talk about business but also you know as
an international student it gives me a
chance to learn about America and like
policymaking and all of these other
issues so this has been definitely one
of my favorite classes although I can
definitely talk about business classes
but this is like my honest answer do you
have a favorite class it's so hard to
pick one so I'll just briefly talk about
two I took a personal tax and investing
class which is arguably
one of the most practical classes you
did I've taken these and I mean some of
the biggest financial decisions you'll
ever make personally and I feel now much
better prepared as I do my taxes as I
think about personally investing that
was great but I just finished up
strategic communication which is kind of
a public speaking class still got a lot
to work on but it was really great just
to like see how you are as a speaker and
really develop that skill set are you
taking the four units one or that too
you know look for unit one yeah cuz I'm
taking the two units Oneg totally it's
an it's an amazing course and I heard
them before unit one we also do writing
as well and I just like missed the
chance to do the writing one move now I
knew but you're gonna do winning writing
exactly that's amazing okay next on can
you please describe the opportunities
available to connect with students from
around the world and learn about the
places and cultures they come from so in
terms of just Stanford's bizarre GSB
classmates a lot of our classmates that
are international lead trips to their
home country um I went to Lebanon with
Lebanese classmates I'll be going to
Africa over winter break with some of
our African classmates I'm leading one
of the global global study trips to
Japan I'm not Japanese but I lived there
for a couple years and I'm going and I'm
leading it with fellow Japanese
classmates so one easy way is you travel
to these countries with your classmates
and then you just you know their hook
they host food nights they each had the
kind of their own identity clubs and and
it's been really great just to learn
about people where they're from I got to
go to Jordan but not with Diana
unfortunately talk about Jordan pretty
often and you told me about your
experience there and I talked about my
trip there and asking questions about
about life there so it's it's a pretty
fruitful conversation yeah and I also
just find a chance to talk with you and
learn about your excuse in Florida is
also like amazing for me as an
international student coming in I feel
that that you see creates this like
bi-directional sort of channel of
communication where we international
students maybe so
students from the US about our culture
but we also get to know a lot about you
culture and yeah as you mentioned just
like one-on-one conversations or trips
or even when people tell their stories
at talk or just like having coffee with
anyone is actually a great genius to to
know about this awesome
so Hana as a Navy veteran
did you draw heavily on your military
experience in your application essays
and are there any recommendations
generally that you want to give on
applying as a veteran definitely so I
think reach out to the veterans Club we
love talking to applicants but in terms
of talking about we have a GSB Veterans
Club page and there's like a little box
you can fill out there and we'll get
your email and and someone from the club
will respond but in terms of the
application I think the best piece of
advice that I got was that it should be
uncomfortable writing it and and it
should really kind of dig to the core of
who you are and for me that did include
a deployment story from the military I
don't think it has to do though I just
think it has to be something personal
that really gets to the core of who you
are and for a lot of veterans that is
something about their military
experience but because the rest of your
application is you know just talking
about all of your accomplishments where
the essay is the one part to really hone
in as who you are as a person
amazing thanks for sharing that so this
next one I'll take it first what
surprised you most at the GSB I think as
an international student there has been
a lot of like surprises to me not only
at the GSB but just like you know moving
from my country and coming to a little
different culture and you know
experiences and all of that but I think
the thing that I was surprised but at
the GSB is my classmates just how
diverse they are how slick amazing and
smart and ambitious and driven people
are around me I think that was one of
the things that surprised me most at the
GSB is that I felt that I managed to
create home away from home and just be
surrounded with people that you can
literally learn from every hour like
basically
what surprised me most of the juice
behind I think especially second year a
lot of times it kind of feels like an
all-day podcast where you're just
constantly listening and learning and
getting your perspective challenged kind
of growing mentally and I think when
you're working your use just you know
showing up at a certain time kind of
grinding and then ending at a certain
time or as an MBA student you just
really get to step back and really have
your perspective challenged and learned
about all these really interesting and
things and that's that's been surprising
yeah amazing well I just want to remind
everyone that they can post their
questions in the Q&A tab for us and we
will be happy to answer them at the time
very many time we have so I know it's
funny we were just talking about this we
have one question about the executive
challenge so someone is asking could you
tell us about the executive challenge
first-year students participate and well
I don't have much to say except that
everyone is so dressed up but it's a
really great just a bonding experience
with your squad so your squad is six
other MBA ones and an MBA to facilitator
that you do this whole first quarter
kind of experience with and then it kind
of culminates in this executive
challenge where you get a case and you
go up and you kind of do a mock role
play with really successful executive
alums and it's just a really good way to
kind of put all that you've learned
first quarter into this experience and I
just what I remember most is just really
bonding with my squad and having a fun
day to kind of culminate then to Fall
Quarter I like to do some roll days it's
like yeah you give us cases and we do
the role plays as if we were executives
now and then towards the end one squad
wins but there's no price could you
comment on how the Bay Area influences
your NBA experience I think it's
somewhat interested in tech this has
been very interesting for me a and
picking the which school I wanted to go
to but the I think just the fact that we
breathe the same air of Silicon Valley
it makes it sound like and
you just cannot not know so much more
Silicon Valley and what's happening here
and like the tech landscape and all of
that and I think that's really really
important as someone who wanted to work
in tech but I would say even if you're
not and I'm curious to hear your opinion
since you are not interested in tech
obviously I feel like there are there's
access to all the other industries as
well and I don't know can you speak more
to if you're interested in finance or
consulting or all the other jobs
definitely so I can speak of someone
that texts great but it's I don't think
it's for me and I'm entrepreneurship
curious but I'm not all in like a lot of
our classmates but I've still loved
being in the Bay one just the access to
the people that are around here
phenomenal we just get fantastic
speakers cycling if they're not already
in the bay they cycle through and visit
so that's been great
you just get to visit very easily all
these awesome companies have gone to
Facebook several times Google uber way
mo but cuz they're all but you know a 10
15 minute ride away and that's been
really cool um and I just feel like
there's this entrepreneurial energy in
the bay and everyone's really trying to
create something or grow something or
change something and that definitely is
you know the Stanford ecosystem goes
well with that yeah and I remember we
both actually organized the women women
in management Trek to your point with us
there's so many companies and they were
within I don't know like 10 15 minute
drive it was amazing to me it's amazing
woman and all these companies and you
know just like hear about their
experience so I think easy access is one
of the biggest thing so we get the gist
be awesome I know what we okay goals
before you started GSB and have they
changed
definitely so my career I do have to get
back to San Diego
my partner's um still down there with
the Navy so consulting made sense
because it allows me to do that but I
wasn't dead set when I came to the GSB I
explored a couple different things I'm
still like maybe I should do something
entrepreneurial next quarter on the side
so I haven't closed that off but overall
I decided that just consulting was the
right fit allows me to kind of get that
analytic skill set that a lot of
classmates already have and really kind
of get that first glimpse at the private
sector before kind of thinking what I
want to do elsewhere
awesome yeah and I think no similar to
you actually opposite I have been sick
for like all my life and so I was like
I'm not going to do tech but once I came
to the GSB I actually didn't realize
that I like tech and I liked it more
than anything else that was offered and
I think that's when I realized that I
wanted to do it even after graduation I
shifted more towards second media
because I could go that's the space I
wanted but I really appreciated the
chance to get to know yourself more and
realize more what are the things that
you like and what are the things that
you don't and I think sometimes
reaffirming the things that we thought
you didn't like it's also like I would
come off there MBA so yeah I'm just
going back to tech but I'm going back
way more prepared I hope about can you
describe your experience with leadership
labs and what you learned most from them
I think what I learned most from lead
labs was I was used to kind of
interacting with like a very specific
type of people like military style
leadership is very different than the
private sector so I think I learned a
lot more of those like soft skills and
how to like come off softer and less
direc and have more influence and you
get pretty close with your squad and
they're very comfortable giving you
honest feedback and how you come off
when you are kind of leading and
management so I think of anything it was
just good honest feedback in a very like
friendly warm environment and then just
also kind of in a squad and a smaller
team you see what other people's
strengths are and you kind of learn from
them as well yeah yeah totally to me as
well I think it's feedback as you
mentioned we keep saying at the GSB that
feedback as a guest love to say that
and I think just getting continuous
feedback because with leadership laughs
you meet every Wednesday to do role
plays and you get feedback on how those
went so I think getting continuous
feedback allows you to see those blind
spots that you don't know about yourself
before anything does that has been my
biggest learning from lead labs
awesome I'll take this one I'll give you
more time to think about it if you were
to go back in time and do something
differently at the GSB what would it be
well it's hard because I say now like we
already are we know what we've been
through and so it's so easy to say I
would be less hard on myself but I would
I don't think that that would have been
the case if I started again I think when
you come into a place where people are
super accomplished and smart and
everyone is just like amazing you start
doubting yourself and that could cause
you to become really really hard on
yourself at least in my case and things
ended up to be really really fine and
I'm good I'm in my second year I like
I'm interviewing for jobs everything's
super fine so I wish that I had this
mindset coming in but I know that it's
hard but this has been just my own
experience would you do anything
different yes this was a very easy one
to answer I think I over committed on
some extracurriculars year one and the
issue with that is then you don't have
the bandwidth her capacity for
extracurriculars later on so you get to
GSB and they're all these kind of shiny
objects and you want to do it all and I
I think I said yes to too many of them
and now second year there are these
great opportunities I'm like I don't
really have the time or capacity for
that so looking back here when I would
have really thought about each thing
before I committed to it and really been
kind of like ruthlessly prioritizing
those things and then just really asking
myself what will I get out of this
extracurricular involvement so overall
like being president that's Club has
been great leading the Japan global
study trip that's going to be great but
there are a couple other ones I'm like
is this really worth the time commitment
awesome well this this is great that you
mentioned that
we have a question actually about the
extracurricular activities so can you
tell us what are some of the most
popular extracurricular activities here
at the GSB maybe through the lens of
what you do but also other things that
are popular that you haven't done
definitely I think so our buckle fellows
which I'm we're both not we're both like
the most famous things you can do
you'll take touchy-feely as the first
year and then second year you'll be the
MBA - squad facilitator which they're
all right now at an executive challenge
so that's a pretty kind of classic major
time commitment extracurricular
otherwise there's a ton of different
clubs and clubs are like affinity groups
and then clubs are professional kind of
interest and then they're there like
just kind of social you know wine club
or eat Club those have more fun
interests so a lot of people join one of
those and take a leadership position in
those clubs I mentioned a president a
veteran's club that's been great
people also ta I'm ta next quarter for
two real-estate lectures that are very
successful and really great guys so
there's just and then people also like
work at maybe you like a venture capital
firm that has a relationship with the
GSB tons of people are starting their
own companies are working with a
start-up so there's so much
extracurricular stuff going on and it's
it's hard to kind of mention at all
totally and to your point even though
our book is like the most pure or
something I feel like I've done so many
other things and like both of us have
done so many things that are not as
popular but I feel that they were like
they spoke to us maybe your points its
clubs or you know things that you just
enjoy doing like teeing of course or
something that I also not doing work
with the NBA office and just like the
admissions and like speaking to our Nets
I think that's something I really
enjoyed you and I also was on the
distinguished teaching a word committee
where we get to pick like a Stanford
professor that we want to give a word to
that has been extra fun for me so yeah I
would just say that even if you don't
get into one of the most popular
extracurricular activities for whatever
reason
there is just so much to do and I love
this sheet that we have you get when you
get them of like all the extracurricular
activities and how much time commitment
each of them requires so that you can
plan to avoid over committing as human
so you avoid so far this is deep I think
maybe through talk um and we mentioned
talk that's where once a week to
students spend about 30 minutes kind of
like telling their life story and major
events or people that have impacted them
I think from that I just learned like
you really can't judge people or know
what what they're going through or where
they've come from and like you think you
know someone and then you hear their
story and you're like I had no idea
that's just been like been kind of like
a fantastic weekly reminder of you know
the importance of like you don't truly
know someone and showing empathy and
just wanting to hear other people's
stories I don't know that's the most but
that's just something I look forward to
on a weekly basis yeah yeah that's
that's interesting and I think the other
thing that was very valley but for me is
learning about myself as well I think
that we do a lot of sort of
introspective exercises at the GSB and
we spend a lot of time with ourselves
and journal and all of that and in so
many courses that I think you just
become deep with your emotions or like
more introspective and I think just
learning more about yourself has been a
very bad thing for me what are you
looking forward to the most next quarter
my fiscal policy course and also low key
notes are coming next workers so I'm so
super looking forward to even delivering
one or even like getting to know the
stories like ideas to change the world
from our classmates low key notes are
like these kind of 10 minutes head talks
that students given and
really cool but you're getting one but
next I hope so I still like three so
let's see next quarter um so that's when
I'll be teeing I'm planning our big kind
of military service community dinner I
just learned that we've got general
mattis former Secretary of Defense as
our keynote speaker which is pretty
crazy to be emailing with general mattis
and then also our Japan trips in this
spring so kind of the last minute or the
last preps for that so that's kind of
like when all my extracurriculars will
come to a head and looking forward to
like really seeing the fruits of my
labor other than that it's a good time
just go snowboarding easy to get to
Tahoe and as a avid snowboarder I'm also
looking forward to that yeah I have
around five minutes left we've received
so many questions on the application and
again I would sort of ask people to send
the admissions office about them but
maybe we can generally just take one
question could you describe your
application experience and what would
you do differently now that you look
back I think just like a general piece
of advice to all the perspective
students if I were to think about it I
would not have like changed anything
that I did I would probably just like be
less stressed out about the whole thing
honestly what the GSB is interested in
it's just as we mentioned on you so how
can you present your story and what can
you tell and show to people in the in
the application is all that matters I
wouldn't worry about like getting
references from I don't know people that
are really famous in the business world
or something like that I didn't have any
of these like to Jordanian people
recommended me so that's absolutely fine
I would really focus I'm telling my
story and yeah that's it that's what
gets you to GSB I would say yeah I think
what I did well if the application was I
gave myself a ton of time I gave myself
enough time to take the GMAT twice
that was huge gave myself enough time to
really iterate for a couple months on my
essay focus on my recommenders that was
good I actually reread my essay recently
and I don't think it was that good
I probably probably would have gone back
and done that differently I think it's
kind of interesting I probably say what
matters most to me now and why is like
probably change in some ways or at least
I have more clarity about that so I
would say really just focusing you know
when it comes to your essay just honing
in on who you are being authentic
showing how you know you created impact
or how you kind of resonate with the
change lives change organizations change
the world
ethos of Stanford but um it's pretty
introspective and it doesn't come
naturally yeah and I like honestly we
didn't we didn't need to make up
anything or whatever it's like how can
you show your authentic and true self is
it so this me or last question we have
one man so I'll let you really quickly
take care how did your experience your
learning opportunities affect your
perspective the experiential learning
that we did just be like the role plays
and all of that how helpful how did that
shape your perspective and GSB um I
think I think one of the biggest things
do you just learn is like how to have
influence and it's easy to this just
like come out people like pretty
directly and just like how to more
subtly move a conversation don't get
what you want to happen and I'm still
working on that but that's been like a
good thing through the experimental or I
don't know if that's a great answer
almost out of time today but kinda thank
you very much and any final words or
advice for people for like 10 seconds
yeah I think I say Business School is
awesome it's two years to really reflect
on who you are and kind of see that
whole world of professional
opportunities
Stanford's phenomenal but all top
business schools are phenomenal I hope
that you end up here would love to see
you here but you'll you'll be successful
no matter what great thank you everyone
for joining us today thank you everyone
in the audience for participating you
can learn more about the MBA program by
visiting the GSP website at GSP dot
stanford.edu thanks again and have a
great day
you